instead of saying oh my god that was
incredible
their expression should be cristo
of course you did exactly what we'd
hoped you'd do
when i was younger sometimes we'll
literally walk into a client meeting and
have 16 logos
we figured out a way to present them
that
the clients just just adored so we
printed them out
and then we would mount them on foam
core and cut them out
in i think four inch by four inch
squares and we would lay them out in a
neat grid on the pit on the table
and so what's really cool about doing it
this modular way is
they could take the ones they don't like
and move them off to the side and then
we reduce it down to one
back then we didn't do mock-ups and all
the stuff we didn't have all these ideas
and on how to present logos we just
presented the logo
all right how would i do differently
today because i
i did preface it that in my youth that's
what i used to do
i would present lots of ideas i didn't
know what was right or wrong
in terms of like what was right for the
company i knew that the form that it
took aesthetically was right but
now totally different approach now in my
40s
i would try to just present one logo and
the process is
dramatically different what we would do
is have a conversation with a client get
into discovery
and find out what we're trying to do
what the logo or the brand should
achieve
and form an idea about who the end
customer is
what what their life looks like their
pain points and their challenges
and we would build very complex mood
boards we call them stylescapes right
or empathy maps and we would say like
okay the ideal customer of yours looks
like this
speaks like this dresses like this and
lives in this world they're active
they're eating these kinds of things
these are the kinds of colors that they
live in
and we get alignment and agreement on
that so what we want to do is be able to
find a logo that fits
neatly into this world of their ideal
customer like when i was talking to mar
earlier about bentley
you want to take images from the bentley
brand on their website
that speaks to who they are in the
lifestyle
and just put in the new logo and if it
fits it feels right
that's with an existing company but
oftentimes with the clients that we work
with
they're either wanting to grow their
market to a different customer
or their rebranding or their brand new
startup so this is
really helpful to create this empathy
map with images of
who their customers are and through that
we start to define the tone of voice
how they want to sound to the world and
the look and the feel
we want to be bold we want to be
confident we want to be fast we want to
be streamlined
we want to suggest solidarity or or
whatever that we
we've have a 200 year history okay so
maybe it's nostalgic
we work through these in words and ideas
first and we get alignment and
we get people to sign off on that and
then when we go away
we'll do one last step before we design
the logo
we'll go away and say okay based on the
criteria that you described
we're going to show you a bunch of logos
that to us
feel like what you said we just want to
make sure because one person's nostalgia
is somebody else's nostalgia right
we show them that and they are yes this
is it
so it's almost like we're pre-designing
the logo beforehand
so if bentley in their desire to rebrand
they're like we want to get rid of the
wings
and and mark actually didn't have a
conversation with them
pretty much every exploration he did
would be now moot and he'd go back to
the drawing board and he would feel like
you
mother you know so that's why it's
really important to have these
conversations
to re to expand what it can be and then
to reduce it
my design professor would call it like
this double funnel system where it opens
up at the beginning
it narrows down and then opens up one
more time for exploration and then it
narrows down and then you're done
so at that point we present one logo
[Music]
and instead of saying oh my god that's
incredible
their expressions should be christo
of course you did exactly what we'd
hoped you do
based on all the conversations so you're
looking to get perpetual alignment with
the client
before you do the work and this is
really really important and if you guys
want to know more about this process if
it seems like
is this scripted like how did he say all
this it's because this is
part of our logo design process it's in
our logo design course
right mark yes it is
yes gee real smoother mark
yeah and mark wanted me to remind you
guys that during this
this global pandemic that we're all
suffering through and that
all of our courses are 20 off i think
yeah i'm gonna have to go and buy your
logo course
that could even be a promo for it
that was a smooth transition yeah except
for when i handed the baton to mark